émilie nicolas paul journet jonathan
trudeau bonsoir
on attendait bien oui bon mais c'est
bien parti tout va bien alors on je
voulais vous dire un petit mot je sais
que c'était pas prévu mais comme
c'est un gel quand même complet des
armes de poing est ce que les maires de
ce pays qui disait ne veut pas gérer ça
la pièce donnez nous des règles du jeu
claires est ce que là pour les armes de
poing jonathan trudeau à votre avis
est-ce que monsieur trudeau vient de
donner ce que les provinces et les
villes voulaient à votre vie mais pas
exactement
une interdiction complète mais je pense
qu'il ya là un bon début a assurément
mieux que ce qui avait été présenté il
ya quoi 2 à peu près de saugues où on
voulait mettre carrément le singe sur
les épaules la responsabilité sur les
épaules des municipalités puisque chacun
est un des législations qui soit
viril et qui soit différent donc à
première vue ça semble bien moi je me
soucie le fait que ce soit bouquet de
mesures comme on dis donc qu'est le site
de ce concept de drapeaux rouges aussi
pour des personnes qui représentent un
risque pour elle même ou pour autrui de
suspendre des permis de port d'armes
pour les personnes avec qui sont
incapables d'harcèlement ou des choses
comme ça donc ce qu'il faudra analyser
tous les détails parce que le projet de
loi personne ne peut le consulter avant
lui phil technique était enfin aux
journalistes une heure après la
conférence de presse qui est assez
particulier les gens devront donc les
réactions de la première vue ça
ressemblait d'avancé par rapport à ce
qui a déjà été proposé par le
gouvernement oui oui vous avez raison le
communiqué moi j'entraîne ici pour
venait d'avoir le le communiqué sans les
détails un millier nicolas petit mot
peut-être ça
c'est sûr qu est ce qu avait circulé
comme information avant l'annoncé cet
après midi c'était que y aller
essentiellement donné la permission aux
provinces d'interdire les arbres les
armes de poing puissances avaient été
critiqués de toute part parce
qu'essentiellement si le québec par
exemple bannissez harb l'appui que le
nouveau brunswick ne le fait pas c'est
très facile de conduire d'une province à
l'autre n'est pas de postes frontaliers
interprovincial donc c'était ça la
crainte qu'ils avaient ceci dit avec la
mesure qui quitte en ce moment qui sera
remplacé ça fait rien pour enlever les
armes de poing qui sont présentement en
circulation légal de la circulation donc
ça répond pas aux besoins qui avait été
qui avait dénoncé par les mères puis la
même chose pour les mesures drapeau
rouge une critique qui a poli je me
souviens le collectif avait fait c'était
que sam est essentiellement la
responsabilité sur les victimes
potentielles ou les victimes réelles
dalil en justice dira qu'une personne
peut être dangereuse qui demandait
c'était que ce soit sans seulement la
justice des services de police qui fasse
ces demandes là plutôt que les victimes
elles-mêmes qui a le fardeau de faire ça
donc cette critique leur reste valide
puis je pense qu'en terminant faut
vraiment dire que la grande majorité des
des armes à feu sont en circulation à
montréal qui sont utilisés dans des
crimes dans une grande partie qu'ils
sont déjà des armes illégales qui
viennent des états unis c'est vraiment
les mesures sur le renforcement des
frontières puis qui fait une grosse
différence sur les armes à feu réelles
qui circulent qui circulent à montréal
la même chose pour les armes à feu qui
sont des armes à feu sans numéro de
série qu'on a eu de la difficulté à voir
doudou est d'où elles proviennent qui
sont pas des armes légales aussi donc ça
fait pas une grosse différence océan
bleu à moins qu'on ait des mesures pour
ce pur nouvo des frontières ouais mais
si je me recule de plusieurs mètres paul
c'est quand même au texas à 18 ans il
est allé lors de son anniversaire et
s'acheter une arme comme on s'achète de
la gomme balloune là j'en vois quand
même un signal à chaque fois qu'une
pièce législative que c'est pas des
joujoux là c'est pas quelque chose qu'on
doit facilement obtenir
non sas envoie un message fort mais en
même temps on voit que c'est pénible
d'envoyer un tel message parce que
regarder yeux la position des libéraux
en 2020 seul en 2021 puis celle en 2022
ils ont reculé sur leurs promesses il ya
un an tellement que le collectif police
se souvient avait dit jeter votre projet
de loi poubelle il est pas bon puis ils
ont changé leur position à la campagne
électorale et puis il arrive et
j'insiste là dessus avec quelque chose
de complètement inédit offrir une
conférence de presse avant on lise je
dois donc moi je suis un peu sur mes
gardes quant à mes commentaires parce
que
on a procédé dans l'ordre inverse
inversement quand gouvernement est fier
de son projet de loi il sait pas de le
cacher puis d'empêcher les journalistes
de lire avant poser des questions aux
élus c'est normal et restez sur vos
gardes en effet le briefing technique
ont lieu maintenant actuellement toi
qu'on peut pas parler notre journaliste
ilia l'intérieur bon grosse fin de
semaine politique je fantasme sur le
gros et la louisianisation possible du
québec
je convaincu une majorité québécois sont
d'accord pour que le gouvernement
fédéral nous transfère ses pouvoirs au
gouvernement du québec sq pour ça que je
demande aux prochaines élections le
mandat fort pour aller négocier ça avec
le gouvernement fédéral une question de
survie pour notre nation si on continue
d'avoir cette partie de l'immigration
choisie par ottawa qui acceptent la
moitié des immigrants qui parlent pas
français ben là ça peut donner une
question de temps avant qu'on devienne
une louisiane donc fois que puisse
expliquer ça aux québécois sur sa
première étape
est-ce qu'on va expliquer souvent aussi
c'est ce que je vous montrais il ya
différentes catégories dans
l'immigration immigration économique ce
que contrôle le québec depuis le fameux
accord ça c'est des chiffres de
2021 ça c'est le québec le jusqu'à 25000
regroupement familial de 11 mai la 11004
ça pour cette année-là réfugiés ça c'est
ce que le canada contrôle aussi deux
catégories donc regroupement familial et
réfugiés c'est un mur alors si on isole
le regroupement familial mettons ces
douze mille la moitié ne parle pas
anglais c'est 6000 son élève les enfants
selon des quelques surfaces utilisez
vous un calcul ce midi son élève enfin
il reste 2000 est ce que le regroupement
familial va sauver le québec jonathan
by en attendant le premier ministre ces
quelques milliers là nous mènerait
directement au bord du précipice qui
voudrait dire qu'il était gelée
situation est critique n'y a personne
qui peut dire que tout va bien au niveau
du passé particulièrement dans la grande
région de montréal c'est important qu'on
conciliateur j'ai l'impression que
françois legault en fin de semaine se
chercher un message à sortir de ce
congrès le bien des gens qui avaient dit
oui on regarde les propositions alors
qu'on parle de déflation de coût de la
vie et ses terrains ça semblait bien
même son niveau de ce qu'on lui cherche
un message fort au sortir de ce congrès
là j'ai l'impression qu'il ya mène
peut-être finalement été un peu trop
fort parce qu'il ya des discussions avec
des gens de son entourage cet après midi
j'ai satie conclure peut même
rétropédaler c'est à dire contre c'est
sûr que l'immigration se la joue qui est
important mais de là parce que ça va
être l'enjeu de la prochaine campagne
électorale et qui êtes vous pour parler
d'autres priorités du coup les vis de
l'inflation et ecce terra donc je pense
qu'il voulait amoureux message dans un
message fort et le petit était un petit
peu tout repos
c'est ballot drôle wingles il y avait
quoi que link préparé mais il y en a
pris eux depuis le magnifier de sorts
que
peut-être trop c'est comme pas assez
paul
la louisiane moi je me suis dit il s'est
échappé avec cet exemple l'homme qui
pour le moins étonnant faut-il rappeler
que jamais eu plus que le tiers des
habitants de la louisiane qui parlaient
français peuvent pas de loi pour
protéger le français je pense pas que
c'était le meilleur exemple mais il
l'avait déjà évoqué en anglais il ya
deux mois je crois donc ce n'est pas la
première fois et moi ce qui m'étonne
c'est qu'il accorde tant d'importance au
volet du regroupement familial vous
l'avez dit c'est dix mille personnes la
moitié d'entre elles ne parlent pas
français mais à leur arrivée
le regroupement familial
ce sont les enfants et les conjoints des
nouveaux arrivants les enfants vont
devoir aller à l'école en français donc
dès qu'ils m'ont parlé français assez
rapidement par la suite c'est une
question presque de dignité si on fait
venir quelqu'un on va pas lui demander
de se couper de sa famille comme premier
geste pour l'intégrer dans la société
et comment dire pour le move est
inélégant donc vois ça m'étonne qu'on
accorde tant d'importance sur cet aspect
là et je note aussi la symétrie entre la
menace selon monsieur lebon la survie de
la nation rien - très dangereux et les
moins qu'il est prête à prendre et 10
qui veulent avoir un mandat fort il a
déjà un bandeau fort tout ce qui lui
reste comme dans son coffret outil c'est
d'aller chercher un référendum sectoriel
mais ça n'intéresse pas parce qu'un
référendum québécois qui emballe
papillon peur de ce mot là non c'est un
peu étrange et beaucoup de traits de
décapage à travers le discours politique
afin cette fin de semaine ouais ml vos
premières impressions face à sète
cette déclaration de monsieur le groupe
va d'abord je sais pas s'il ya des
francophones la louisiane qui nous
écoute mais j'espère qu'ils vont envoyer
des lettres ouvertes dans les journaux
québécois dans les prochains jours je
pense qu'elles sont et pour utiliser la
louise en com et à force ça serait le
fun d'avoir des louisianais qui nous
donne l'heure juste parce que ce genre
de métaphores ils peuvent seulement
tenir s'il ya une ignorance en fait de
la réalité la bonne ceci étant dit je
peux juste réitéré ce qui était dit puis
rajouter que lorsqu'il lorsque quelqu'un
comme le premier ministre dit que les
migrants choisi par ottawa et là je
paraphrase
menace l'existence de la nation
québécoise ça veut dire qu'un paquet de
québécois originaire de l'immigration
qui écoutent ce puits qui sont pas
rassurés du tout parlé preuve les propos
que le premier ministre vient dire c'est
leur enfant aussi qu'ils cotisent c'est
comme si nos familles ont fait mon père
est venu ici par unification familiale
est une menace et je pense que c'est
c'est que c'est important d'avoir le
l'analyse de de ce qui se passe de ce
qui est dit puis les conséquences qui
est politique mais aussi de simplement
prendre le temps de dire quelques uns
premier ministre québec dit des choses
comme ça il ya des gens qui sont issus
de ces groupes là qui écoute c'est
qu'ils trouvent ça inquiète je ne sais
pas si franchement elle prémunit contre
leur vote éventuel mais c'est sûr que si
on avait qui auraient pu être tentés de
voter pour l'anc avec des déclarations
comme ça c'est sûr que c'est pas
exactement vendra donc je n'allais on
est dedans on est dans la stratégie là
on voulait
peut-être des fois vouloir trop sur
simplifier certains messages donnez moi
un mandat fort pour que j'ai cherché des
pouvoirs en immigration scci ce que ça
donne deux d'avancé peut-être trop
stratégique le jonathan ben je sais que
je pense c'est est en phase avec le
hockey était là on voyait que tout
tournait autour du concile de la fierté
dieu du nationaliste mais lorsqu'il est
une des conférences par exemple donne
une présentation séparent le ministre de
l'agriculture de la montagne sur la
fierté sur le nationalisme on se rend
compte que pour la cac ce n'est pas on
parle pas d'une fierté d'être caquistes
il s'arroge la fierté d'être québécois
carrément c'est vraiment on pousse le
concept du nationalisme très très loin
c'était cette idée là dans leur
confrontation avec le fédéral sur des
questions identitaires sur les questions
d'immigration saveur plus en phase avec
tout le reste du discours du congrès
seulement je pense que sur cette note là
en particulier on ne on est
bon très bien
d'ailleurs dont on a parlé la semaine
dernière dans les déclarations du
fédéral sur la loi 96 qu'ils sont
attentifs qui vont voir qui peut-être
français si cela c'est la même c'est la
même réaction le monsieur legault se
nourrit de south il
oui pile fédéral se nourrit du saulcy
faut pas croire qu'il ya seulement
monsieur legault qui politise ces enjeux
là pour en faire un bien partisans
regardez la réaction du ministre de la
justice du canada david la médecine au
lendemain de l'adoption de la loi 96 il
va faire une déclaration sur la loi 21
pour dire qu'il voudrait plaider en cour
suprême pour un resserrement quelconque
encadrement de la disposition de
dérogation la clause nonobstant clause
dérogatoire
c'est pas banal ça parce que ça
ça équivaut à revoir les conditions même
du rapatriement de la constitution
quand même toujours rappeler que huit
provinces qui étaient contre 7 qui ont
été convaincues de signer la
constitution
à cause de cette proposition dérogation
évidemment le québec le post signé me
suis là mais ti
banalise tout ça et ils annoncent qu'ils
veulent revenir sur ce compromis
historique et il le fait avant même que
la cause a été entendue devant la cour
d'appel point porte qu'on pense sur le
fond qu'on soit d'accord ou non avec ce
qu'est le ministre les métiers propose
ça reste qu' il y avait une stratégie
partisans très très forte là dedans dont
les batteries sont toujours meilleures
quand il ya deux personnes qui ont envie
de se battre puis c'est le chaos ici oui
ml nico exactement pas donner
l'impression que le fédéral ne s'en prit
ne se privera pas de cette bataille non
plus monsieur trudeau comme plus rien à
perdre il est assuré de continuer
pendant tout le terme de son mandat
grâce au npd et là j'ai comme s'ils
étaient des complexés la i10 très bien
il ya des batailles que je veux mener
aussi au québec là on sent durcissement
des deux côtés en effet enfin enfin
durcissement après de dire que je pense
qu'il ya beaucoup de choses qui ont été
dits cette semaine sur la position du
gouvernement fédéral intervenant dans la
loi 21 plat la loi 96 les deux en fait
c'est sûr que le fait que le
gouvernement fédéral devait y avoir son
mot à dire dans dans ce dossier là sa
banque aux primes c'est pas du tout est
légitime ceci dit c'est la façon dont
ces dix la façon donc ses communiqués
qui peut aller ensuite en fait aidé
françois legault qui veut prétendre que
tout ça est un affrontement québec
contre le canada alors que plein de gens
au québec qui sont aussi critiques de
ces lois là donc
le théâtre de l'affrontement se joue
effectivement à deux et il ya beaucoup
de gens au canada anglais dans les
autres provinces qui sont très contents
quand quand les le gouvernement fédéral
n'y va pas avec les gants blancs sur la
critique de ces lois là pour des raisons
qui n'ont rien à voir avec le québec
mais plus avec le sentiment qui eux
souhaitent avoir un gouvernement fédéral
qui fort donc il ya un ensemble de jeux
politiques c'est sûr que se joue sur ces
questions là et pendant que ces jeux
politiques le se joue bien sûr sur les
minorités qui sont touchés par ces lois
là qui se retrouve à être un peu des
balles de ping pong et au travail tout
ce que ne permet pas de nous n'oublions
pas qu'il ya des relations humaines a
pas d'amour perdues entre justin trudeau
et françois legault prince le groupe qui
est même un déficit par rapport à
réajuster trop tôt on se souvient des
épisodes la dernière campagne électorale
wire policier d'expérience qui m'a déjà
dit que particulièrement en politique la
vengeance est un plat qui se mange froid
j'ai l'impression qu'on n'a pas fini de
voir justin trudeau donner des fins de
non recevoir ou de
agissent comme la peste
ouais mais en même temps ça peut aider
vous aussi monsieur legault beaucoup
donc tout seul jusqu'où ça va nous
amener en a qui rêvent un autre
référendum est ce notre conseil national
de québec solidaire on entend on va
écouter un extrait il ya des militants
qui ont tous n'ont pas aimé que québec
solidaire vote pour la loi 96 on
respecte la loi 96 on écoute
c'est un défi
de longue date à québec solidaire de
concilier
notre fonctionnement démocratique et les
exigences du parlement je pense que nos
militants militantes font leur travail
d'exprimer leurs opinions ils nous
disent ce qu'ils pensent de nos
décisions passées sont un parti
démocratique ce soit par ses transports
tour de table rapide là tu émilie
nicolas les militants qui n'ont pas aimé
autre que certains militaires n'ont pas
aimé l'appui du parti à la loi 96
essentiellement québec solidaire c'est
du critique d'un ensemble de mesures
dans la loi 96 dont la question des six
mois pour
l'accès aux services en français pour
les migrants et la passion ça touche les
communautés autochtones sinon votre voté
pour pareil parce que on aime le
renforcement par exemple de la loi 101
sur certains autres aspects alors que
par exemple le parti québécois n'a pas
jugé utile de voter pour le projet de
loi même si bien sûr le parti québécois
n'est pas content le renforcement de la
loi 100 de la loi 101 donc le québec
solidaire s'est mis dans une position
extrêmement bizarre où ils pouvaient
très bien dire qu'ils étaient pour pour
pour pour certains renforcement de la
loire sans sans voter à plus pour la
loire est passé de toute façon et ils
vont passer en fait je pense les
prochains mois essayer de réparer les
pots cassés avec une partie dans base
militante c'est vraiment pas brillant je
trouve d'avoir fait ce avant de campagne
électorale ou top besoin les militants
pour faire ton travail de terrain
jonathan il se disait que l' inverse
aurait peut-être été pire envers
d'autres millan fin bref il que vous en
pensez
mais moi j'ai l'impression que peu
importe la fonction il aurait fuit il
aurait dû perdre ça semblait très
difficile d'essayer de gérer ce partisan
moi je trouve qu'on permet à medica
potion de québec solidaire à l'assemblée
nationale elle était responsable
c'est-à-dire de reconnecter avec des
pompes aux aspects des moins bons de
s'engageait les modifier éventuellement
mais de paul et si tout le terrain libre
à laquelle j'avais regardé le mieux que
nous qui voulions complètement
rapidement apporter des changements pour
celui là la loi soeur malheureusement ça
semble plutôt difficile de pas sont
partis pour gabriel audubon et je pense
qu'on doit pas finir devant ce genre de
situation se répéter à québec solidaire
paul je m'excuse je vais passer au pq
tout de suite et on va écouter un petit
extrait de paul st pierre plamondon qui
dit nous on reste debout peu importe le
contexte qu'on va parler de référendum
est ouverte on écoute
on importe ce que vous dites
l'indépendance du québec elle est
nécessaire et elle est urgente et dans
ce contexte haulotte notre message pour
vous c'est la cac ne pas besoin de votre
vote mais l'indépendance du québec m oui
c'était samedi charles iv ou jean dit de
200 événements du pq québec quand le
parti québécois proposait pas de
référendum on leur disait vous cachez
votre option le ils ont proposé un pion
dit les québécois ont veulent pas donc
on va pas les critiques et d'une chose
et de son contraire
j'ai l'impression pour le parti
québécois le défi c'est de s'accrocher à
son vote indépendantiste et tenir bon et
survivre à la prochaine élection parce
que peut-être que françois legault va
bientôt devenir un allié objectif parce
que s'ils s'engagent dans des débats
avec le dans des combats avec le fédéral
sur la loi 21 la disposition des
rogations
affrontements sur la loi 96
l'immigration peut-être que le pq pour
ont tué dix rebelles si vous vous
revendiquez une langue ni rien de tel
que vous devriez revenir au bercail la
preuve est loin de là dessus ils ont
actualisé le budget de l'indépendance de
françois legault est bon en soi le goût
et s'il cire est encore jeune atteindre
très rapidement
bah moi ce que je suis ce que je
constate c'est que
[Musique]
j'avais
mais c'est beaucoup de temps d'aller pas
voté pour
nous on a besoin de vote de votre vote
pour sa survie quatre mois et demi avant
l'élection ça demande quand même à quel
point les situations les plus toxiques
secteur au parti québécois survivre et
millencolin fait effectivement pour le
parti québécois ça va être très
compliqué dans les prochains mois merci
à vous trois merci à très bientôt au
revoir bonne soirée pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit
oh